bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
met alors à l'époque vous déclariez que
la profession des sapeurs-pompiers
obéira s'il devait y avoir une
obligation vaccinale on est on en est
aujourd'hui à la troisième dose comment
ça s'est passé
comme pour les autres comme pour les
autres doses qui ont été quand tes
administrés aux sapeurs pompiers avec ce
devoir d'obligations c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui les sapeurs pompiers c'est
une intervention de ce que cette seconde
donc une intervention toutes les sept
secondes au contact de la population on
se doit d'être protégé pour protéger les
autres aussi donc aujourd'hui on
constate une chose simple c'est que avec
l'action de la vaccination et cette
campagne de vaccination qui a été menée
les sa part conclu aujourd'hui on
vacciner 25 % de la population française
donc près d'un quart voire un peu plus
d'un quart de la population donc on se
devait déjà d'une part de rester dans la
continuité du schéma vaccinal pour
maintenant être pleinement est toujours
associé à cette vaccination est à la
poursuite on va dire de l'armement des
vaccinodromes des taxibus des unités
justement mobile pour permettre à l'état
de faire la vaccination en plus loin
dans tous les territoires donc voilà
aujourd'hui ce bouclier là ça nous
permet effectivement de pouvoir être au
contact d'une population au travers des
interventions parce que la volée
l'évolution des interventions ont
grandement évolué puisque on a quasiment
tous se retrouver une vie normale et que
notre activité opérationnelle se veut
aujourd'hui accrue dans ce domaine là
que ce soit au niveau incendie que son
niveau se courait sur dur pour personne
que ce soit pour les opérations diverses
mais aussi pour le secret les crises
événements naturels que l'on se doit de
préparer donc il s'agit aujourd'hui de
pouvoir continuer à être non seulement
le premier rempart mais aussi l'exemple
en ce qui concerne cette obligation
vaccinale qui pour l'ensemble de la
population de permet enfin de voir le
bout du tunnel alors avez vous des
chiffres en savez vous quelle est la
proportion des pompiers qui ont refusé
de se soumettre à cette obligation
vaccinale
écoutez le refus c'est comme dans toutes
les corporations il y en a il y en a eu
certes il est certaine on peut pas
dénombrer effectivement l'ensemble des
gens qui n'ont pas souhaité vacciner ça
reste vraiment à
marche vraiment très minimal donc
aujourd'hui parlons plutôt des gens qui
ont souhaité se faire vacciner qui
correspond à plus de 98% des
sapeurs-pompiers aujourd'hui tant que ce
qui ce qui permet grandement aujourd'hui
d'accomplir encore nos missions ses
munitions qui donne compliqué
aujourd'hui donc voilà on préfère parler
de ce qui a effectivement permis
justement de pouvoir aujourd'hui venir
aux besoins des appels au secours de la
population
oui bien sûr ça reste une petite
minorité qui a refusé de se soumettre à
cette obligation vaccinale mais j'ai
quand même une dernière question
concernant cette minorité la règle
c'était donc la suspension du salaire si
un bon client ne se vacciner pas donc
avec un arrêt total en du travail est ce
que ça vous a fait peur est ce que vous
avez eu peur de manquer de personnel
finalement
d'accord on l'a on a tout le temps
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que les effectifs
en caserne mais que ce soit le
renforcement est due à la fois la
disponibilité aussi à la récurrence on
va dire des événements climatiques des
événements sanitaire des événements
incendie qui se veut qu'aujourd'hui on a
l'impression de découvrir comment
fonctionne la vigne aux sapeurs pompiers
il faut savoir que les difficultés pour
armer les agences et sont des choses que
l'on rencontre au quotidien et notamment
dans des situations exceptionnelles
aussi cool on se doit d'avoir toujours
les forces en première ligne et aussi
les forces en deuxième jaune pour
réarmer les centres de secours donc
armer les centres de secours avec 7 on
va dire cette obligation vaccinale
aujourd'hui on est simplement dans la
dans la continuité on cherche évidemment
au quotidien à pouvoir rendre rencontre
sur notre manière de dar mais les
centres de secours ces centres de
secours correspondent aujourd'hui à un
schéma opérationnel départemental tracy
et qui donne des effectifs ces effectifs
sont évidemment pour la plupart bien
entendu maintenues pour la protection de
la population voilà c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui coville paco vide c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui vaccination pas
vaccination les cazéens les centres de
secours directeurs départementaux
d'ascendis de secours
continuer à armer correctement les
centres de secours et à la marge ce même
poste pas de conséquences dramatiques de
ce côté là et regarder un martien
d'avoir été avec nous en direct d'avoir
répondu à nos questions jean balcou êtes
le directeur de la communication au sort
de la fédération nationale des
sapeurs-pompiers de france mercière